we now see a significant movement of
troops away from kiev
to regroup
re-arm
and re-supply
and the shifter focus to the east
in the coming weeks
we expect
a further russian push
in the eastern and southern ukraine
to try to take the entire donbass
and to create the language to occupy
crimea
so this is a crucial face of the war
and as
ukraine faces this new offensive
nato foreign ministers will discuss
what more we will do
allies are determined to provide further
support to ukraine
including anti-tank weapons air defense
systems and other equipment
allies have also increased
humanitarian assistance and financial
aid
nato will also look to provide cyber
security assistance
and equipment to help ukraine protect
against chemical and biological threats
i expect we will also decide to do more
for nato's other partners which are
vulnerable to russian threats and
interference
including georgia
and bosnia-herzegovina
by stepping up our
political and practical support we can
help our partners strengthen their
resilience
and prevent any future aggression
on thursday we will be joined by
ukrainian foreign minister dimitro
coleba
he will update us on the latest
developments including kiev's
negotiations with moscow
finland sweden
georgia
and the european union will be at the
table and we will be joined by nato's
asia-pacific partners
australia japan new zealand and the
republic of korea
because this crisis has global
implications
which concerns us all
we see that china has been unwilling to
condemn russia's aggression
and has joined moscow
in questioning the right of nations to
choose their own path
at the time where
authoritarian powers are pushing back
on the rules-based
international order it is even more
important for democracies to stand
together and protect our values
so i expect we will agree to deepen
nato's cooperation
with our asia-pacific partners
including in areas such as arms control
cyber hybrid and technology
working more closely together will make
us all safer and more secure
allies will also discuss our work to
develop nato's next strategic concept
in time for the madrid summit in june
it will guide the alliance as we adapt
to a new security reality
it will address
the implications of russia's aggressive
actions
and our future relationship with moscow
for the first time it will also need to
take account of china's growing
influence and coercive policies on the
global stage
which pose a systemic challenge to our
security and our democracies
our next strategic concept must also
consider climate change terrorism and
emerging and disruptive technologies
at our summit last year we agreed to
establish a billion euro nate nato
innovation fund and defence innovation
accelerator for the north atlantic diana
this week
ministers will endorse the charter of
diana setting up how it will be how it
will work
it will include a network of nearly 60
innovation sites in europe and north
america
enabling nato to develop and test new
capabilities for our defense
all together the initial footprint will
cover 20 nato nations
representing a true transatlantic
endeavor and we expect it will continue
to expand in the future
diana will work with
academia and the private sector
including startups and entrepreneurs
so that allies regardless of their size
or their location
can harness the best of new technology
and keep our people safe
our meeting this week is an important
milestone
as we continue to adapt our lines for
the future
and with that i'm ready to take your
questions
okay
we'll start with
the national news agency of ukraine
gentlemen in the second row uh dmitry's
national news agency of ukraine uh
secretary general uh by the mass
killings and atrocities in the ukrainian
cities
russian troops absolutely clearly
demonstrated what does it mean uh a
russian policy of denudification
so-called
but my question is not about the nato
stance about that uh
uh is there any hope that uh nato allies
will at least understand that there is
some kind of real nazi regime arising in
russia and the second part of the
question is what nato really can do to
prevent
the tragedy of a scale
as we've seen
during the second world war
thanks
what we now see is the brutality is a
scale and a scope of war that we haven't
seen
in europe since the second world war
uh and this is extremely serious it's uh
it's horrific and of course it causes
suffering for ukrainian people but it's
also dangerous for all of us
and the and we see the
the nature of president putin's war his
lack of respect for in for the rule of
law for international rules
and also his lack of respect
for um
basic human rights including the right
to life
for all those who are killed in this
conflict
and um and this is the most serious
security challenge uh
we have faced uh since the second world
war
and uh it has uh
triggered a very comprehensive and
strong response for from the whole nato
alliance
we provide nato allies provide support
to ukraine
uh and we have provided support ukraine
for many years
uh nato allies had trained tens of
thousands of ukrainian troops
many of whom are now on the front line
fighting against the
russian invaders
nato allies have equipped ukrainian
military for many years and
after the invasion allies stepped up and
provided even more support
we see the effect of this support every
day on the battlefield
because it is first and foremost the
bravery the courage of ukrainian
soldiers
but of course their help and the
equipment they have received from nato
allies have enabled them to put up much
more resistance
to fight back in a much more effective
way that the russian expected they
totally underestimated uh the strength
of the ukrainian armed forces and nato
allies have medicare they will further
support
ukraine
not least in light of the atrocities we
have seen in buja and other places in
ukraine
so
allies
are providing support alice will
continue to provide support
because
it is absolutely unacceptable what we
see president putin
is doing against the sovereign
independent and democratic nation in
europe
okay we had cnn first first row
thank you very much nick robertson from
cnn
and president zielinski has said that he
will
not accept a piece unless all russian
troops leave ukraine pre-february 23rd
lines can nato accept a peace that
leaves russian troops in ukraine beyond
their february 23rd positions
nato's task is to provide support to
ukraine and we do so
with the modern military equipment
financial military support
and also humanitarian support then it is
for the ukrainian government and for
president salensk and the people of
ukraine to decide what kind of peace
arrangements they can accept
we know that there is a very close link
between uh what they can achieve at the
negotiating table and their strength on
the battlefield so the stronger we are
able to make them uh on the battlefield
the more support
the more strength we can provide
to the ukrainian armed forces
the better results they can achieve at
the negotiating table so it's not for me
to give advice but it's for me and nato
allies to provide them support and then
at the end of the day for the ukrainian
authorities for the ukrainian president
and for the ukrainian people to decide
what kind of agreements they can accept
we will never recognize
illegally occupied territories
so nato allies have not recognized
illegally annexed crimea and we will
never recognize the legally uh occupied
territories okay al jazeera
what we've seen in uh butcher is
basically we can't conclude anything
else than that despite the fact that
nato has been supporting ukraine ukraine
has insisted from the beginning it
wasn't enough we can't we can only
conclude that the world and nato has
been watching while these atrocities
have been happening in bucha
can we can we now conclude that nato is
ending up at the wrong side of history
that's my first question and the second
one is you say we are increasing our
efforts
in uh ukraine how are we gonna how are
you gonna prevent that another butcher
will happen in the future in the next
coming weeks when the offenses is going
to increase thank you
this is president putin's war he is
responsible he has made this war by his
own choice
and and he is responsible for the
atrocities for the casualties uh for uh
the whole effects of the war which you
are seeing every day taking place uh on
the ground in ukraine
then our responsibility is to support
ukrainians and we have done that for
many years
and the the training equipment nato
allies have provided since 2014
has
helped them so they are in a totally
different position now than ukraine was
back in 2014 when russia invaded for the
first time the ukrainian armed forces
are bigger
better equipped better trained better
led today than in 2014 uh not least
because of support that nato allies have
provided for more than eight years
we need to
continue to put unprecedented pressure
on president putin
and that's reason why
we are on the right side of history
because we are standing up for our
values
we are
imposing unprecedented economic costs on
russia
and
we have stepped up and have made it
clear and expect allies when they meet
here tomorrow and the day of tomorrow
tomorrow to make clear that they will
continue to further
support ukraine uh with more advanced
equipment and military support but nato
has also not the responsibility
and that is to prevent this conflict
from escalating beyond ukraine
because the suffering we see in ukraine
is horrific
but if this turns into be a full-fledged
war
between a nuclear power
russia and nato
then we will see even more suffering
even more death even more destruction
and that's reason why nato has to make
some hard and difficult decisions
to provide support
but to do that in a way that doesn't
escalate this conflict into a war that
will really be a full-fledged war
between nato and russia and nuclear
power and that's the reality we all have
to face
npr torture
could you tell me what nato's assessment
is realistically of of russia's capacity
to actually launch a chemical or
biological or radiological attack
because you keep warning them against it
and i understand some of this is
classified but there are also experts
who say that russia doesn't have
this capacity and that it's it's
fear-mongering to keep talking about the
fact that they may launch an attack um
so
does the alliance believe that russia
really could do this in a way that would
affect nato countries thanks
i will be careful speculating
but what i would like to say is that it
was that's actually russia has started
to speak about these types of weapons
because they have accused us
the united states nato allies for
preparing the use of biobiological
chemical weapons and this is absolutely
false it's it's not
has nothing to do with with truth uh
whatsoever
and then we it has been necessary for us
to push back and say that no nato and
nato allies are in no way supporting
ukraine in any way
for any use of chemical weapons and that
has been our message then we added two
more points and that is that we
know that uh russia has used
chemical agents before
they have used it against their own
opposition they used it in salisbury and
we have seen that russia has used
chemical
weapons and agents before
we also seen that they have supported
the assad regime in russia in in in
syria where chemical weapons have been
used
but this is first and foremost something
that has been brought into the
discussion by russia accusing us for
preparing use of chemical weapons which
is absolutely wrong us and and ukraine
and second
the same thing goes for for nuclear
weapons
where we have seen the very dangerous
nuclear rhetoric from russia
threatening uh the use of nuclear
weapons um
as part of
the buildup you have seen
in around ukraine even before
the invasion but also after
that
uh enjoyed statement from the last
summit nato mentioned we are providing
taylor road support to partners affected
by russia threats and in
interference and will step up our
assistance to help them etc in april
foreign ministers will consider concrete
proposals for enhance our support to
these partners so what georgia could
expect from this important meeting
tomorrow and the day after tomorrow and
also georgia will present uh so new
minister foreign affairs will present
georgia on this meeting
i look forward to meet the new georgian
foreign minister
and we always look forward to
meet with our highly valued partner
georgia in different
nato meetings uh tomorrow and uh in the
foreign ministerial meeting actually the
day after on thursday
um uh and and george ice is a partner
which uh
uh
we
which is important for nato and and i
expect that the foreign ministers they
will
look into how we can further step up our
support to georgia and uh
for georgia this could
include increase in our support through
the substantial nato georgia package
including the areas of situational
awareness
secure communications
resilience and cyber we can also support
georgia in developing its own cyber
capabilities
and provide additional personnel to the
nato liaison office in georgia there are
concrete steps that can be taken when
ministers
meet on thursday
okay
um thank you very much lee bye from
politico i was wondering if you could
perhaps describe in a bit more detail
and concretely what are the different
options on the table that the ministers
will be discussing for further helping
ukraine thank you
the allies
will discuss
how we can
further support ukraine
this is partly about financial support
partly about
humanitarian support but also of course
partly about
military support both
both uh
non-lethal and lethal military support
which allies have provided for several
years
i'm a bit careful going into the
specific systems
because i think that for operational
reasons it's better that allies actually
provide support
than that we announce every specific
weapon system allies are
transferring over to ukraine
but it's well known that
we speak about advanced weapon systems
we speak about for instance javelins and
other anti-tank weapons which have
proven extremely effective
on the battlefield if there's anything
we have seen is that these
relatively uh as a light weapons
uh have a huge impact
uh and uh when we see all the pictures
from the destroyed russian armor this is
first and foremost a result of these
weapons uh and of course the courage of
the soldiers who are carrying them
um but but i think we have proven the
effectiveness of
of anti-tank weapons delivered by nato
allies
uh the uh the ukrainians have also been
able to
shoot down
advanced
russian planes but also helicopters and
other
drones again because of
advanced
air defense systems delivered by nato
allies
and we are looking into all their
systems and allies are constantly
stepping up and providing more support
partly partly partly as a weapons but
you know we also need fuel you need
ammunition you need a lot of different
types of supplies you need
helmets you need protective gear you
need medical supplies to to run such a
big military operation so
this is partly about high-end
weapon systems but also very much about
the logistics and the
supplies you need to run this kind of
big military operations as the
ukrainians have run now for several
weeks
okay wall street journal
dan michaels with the wall street
journal thank you very much if i could
follow up on the last question um
mr secretary general as you said at the
beginning it looks like the war is
changing um the
russians are regrouping in the southeast
they're no they're now more massed um
they have more armor from crimea from
donbass it would seem that the battle is
going to change qualitatively it's no
longer going to be one where their
ukrainians are picking off over extended
supply lines or isolated troops
do the ukrainians have what they need to
fight what may be a more traditional
type of
ground war
against a more massed russian force or
does nato need to step up with a
different type of weapon system or
different type of support to help the
ukrainians against a much more
concentrated russian occupation force
thank you
so nato allies are in close contact with
ukraine and uh and uh
we will also have the ukrainian foreign
minister coleba coming to the nato
ministerial meeting and i expect that he
will address
uh the needs that ukraine uh have or has
to to to reinforce their troops and to
make sure that they continue to push
back and to
provide fierce resistance against the
invading russian troops
so both the the dialogue between
different nato allies and ukraine but
also the dialogue we have here at nato
is important to make sure that we
deliver as much support as we can
and also that we deliver the
capabilities that ukraine needs
so i expect a meeting tomorrow and the
day after tomorrow will will provide a
platform for that kind of discussions
um
we are now seeing a new face of the war
because russia is really moving out not
only of kiev but also of
most of the north at least reducing
significantly their presence there
because they failed
president putin didn't manage to achieve
the objectives he set for this military
operation
his goal was to take care within days
now he has been there for so many weeks
and still
he has not been able to take care of and
many other cities
in the north
so he's now moving
many of those troops
out of the north
into belarus
down
to the east into russia
and there there will be a remand because
men have lost
a lot of troops in the different units
they will be re-armed
because they've used a lot of ammunition
and they will be re-supplied with
fuel and all the other things they need
food and so on to launch a new big
offensive so what we are expecting is a
new very concentrated russian offensive
in donbass
to try to occupy take the whole of
donbass
that's also the same
area where ukraine has
most of their armed forces
so
this whole buildup will take some time
the repositioning of the russian troops
will take some times some some time some
some weeks
but after that we
we are afraid that we can see a big
russian uh offensive in donbas
with aim to take
donbass
[Music]
in that window
it is extremely important that nato
allies provide support
so we are able to rearm to resupply the
ukrainian
forces
and that's exactly what i expect allies
to do and what exactly are what i expect
allies to discuss at the meeting
tomorrow and the day after tomorrow
um including what times what types of
equipment and how we can enable them to
stand up against and continue
to inflict heavy casualties on the
invading russian forces okay associated
press
thanks for your question mr secretary
general mark from associated press
has nato's drones or satellite imagery
shown any more locations across ukraine
or there are mass
people that have been killed
i'm always a bit
reluctant to go into details about how
we collect intelligence and what kind of
detailed information we have but we are
monitoring very closely
and we have
capabilities surveillance capabilities
that provides us with a lot of
information
and
and
this is important and
it is something which we use in in which
is in a good way uh
because information
best possible situational awareness is
of course
extremely critical in such a dangerous
situation as we see
in ukraine and now okay we have uh vega
we know there's been talks on high level
between nato and nato countries and
finland and sweden
for the latest weeks
and they have started both a process
reviewing whether there will be a
membership application so i want to ask
you about if you want to comment on the
process and
if there has been a discussion
with those two countries about
intermediate security guarantees for
them
in a possible
intermediate period between an
application and a third membership could
be granted thank you
it is for finland and sweden to decide
whether they want to join a nato and
nato will respect
the decision they take regardless of
whether they decide to try to join or
not to join because we respect
decisions by sovereign and independent
nations
i have had
close contact with the political
leadership both in sweden and
and finland
over the last months and also the last
weeks
[Music]
and i have conveyed them the message
that
it's for them to decide of course
but if they
apply
i expect that 30 allies will welcome
them
and
that we will find ways to also address
the concerns they may have about this
interim period
between they have applied and until the
last stratification has taken place
nato is the strongest alliance in
history
and
by standing together we provide
security for all allies
and that we protect values we have in
common with finland finland and sweden
democracy the rule of law
and
and we live in a more dangerous world
so it's even more important that we
stand together
finland and sweden are close partners we
have worked with them trained with them
for many many years and we have also now
since the invasion actually
activated uh some mechanisms we have to
integrate them in finland sweden even
more into
into our deliberations and uh and into
meetings and uh and activities in nato
but of course finland and sweden are not
full members so
they are close partners we work closely
together
but our collective defense
guarantees
they apply for members and only for
members
secretary general
the foreign ministers will also discuss
the new strategic concept and you are
entering the drafting phase now
before the war you have always described
relations between nato and russia with
the 3ds deterrence and defense plus
dialogue
in the new strategic concept do you see
any room for dialogue at all given what
has happened in the meantime and what
kind of outlook
are you suggesting to allies to
contemplate in this
drafting process
thanks a lot
our relationship with russia has
fundamentally changed and russia has
walked away from the nato-russia
founding act agreement we made to
facilitate dialogue between
russia and uh and the nato back in the
1990s
um
so this
this doesn't work in the way
we've actually tried to achieve or the
partnership that the cooperation of
dialogue we have worked for for many
years with roshan uh that doesn't exist
anymore
[Music]
yeah so our relationship with russia has
fundamentally changed
at the same time we we will need to
continue to
engage with russia because russia is our
neighbor
and
and we need to also manage a difficult
relationship
including
issues like
risk reduction transparency
deconfliction and also issues related
related to arms control
but meaningful dialogue as we strived
for before
is
is is not an option
for
russia
which is so blatantly violating
international law
which is using military force
against an independent sovereign nation
as ukraine and which is responsible for
atrocities
for the
the the suffering we see taking place in
ukraine every day
in tv
secretary general sonoma from ntv turkey
i have a follow-up on the strategy
concept question the strategy concept
has been drafted before the war started
in ukraine and you said that at the
beginning of the war that there is a new
reality do you think that there is
enough time 11 weeks by
the summit in
in june to update again
a strategic concept do you envisage to
update also nato 2030 so that the
institution itself nato is ims could
face also the new challenges and do you
for example foresee to increase the
permanent available troops to succur
from 40 000 which is the level today to
60 90 000 or at least for the new
reality thank you
i'm absolutely confident that when the
nato leaders meet
at the nato summit
in the end of or in madrid at the end of
june we will be able to agree updated
and good
news strategic concept
we had started the discussions
and the uh and of course we will take
into account the
uh russian invasion of ukraine as we
finalize the strategic concept
but i think we have to remember that uh
actually we
predicted
uh precisely based on our intelligence
uh as early as last fall that it was
highly likely that russia was going to
invade ukraine so that has been part of
our deliberations uh for many months
of course there is a difference between
having intelligence predicting that
innovation will take place and actually
see it takes place as we saw on the 24th
of february but it was not a big
surprise
i think it's hardly any other invasion
in the world or at least few other
innovations we have seen
up through history which has been more
predicted than the invasion uh by russia
into ukraine
therefore also nato was well prepared
and actually we have been
stepping up since the first russian
invasion of ukraine back in 2014.
since 2014 since russia went in and
illegally annexed crimea
and
these stabilized and supported the
separatists in donbass in eastern
ukraine
nato has implemented the biggest
reinforcement of collective defense in
the generation
with the battlegroups in the eastern
part of the alliance after years of
reducing defense spending all allies
have increased defence spending
and uh and we have tripled the size of
the nato response force
uh and and actually
uh the weeks before the invasion
we
increased the readiness of the national
response force we increased the presence
of nato troops in eastern part alliance
before they invaded
because we saw
the intelligence we saw the clear
warnings about that was most likely
going to happen then of the invasion
we have stepped up further
and now we have 40 000 troops on the
direct nato command in the eastern part
of the alliance there are hundred
thousand u.s troops in europe uh
uh significant in greece
uh and then we have hundreds of
thousands of nato troops on heightened
alert
all of these supported by
hundreds of ships and uh and planes uh
substantial naval and and and and air
power
so we have already
since 2014
uh
implemented
a huge reinforcement to our collective
defense and then on top of that added
some immediate responses as a result of
the invasion uh
in in february
but we face a new security reality
and therefore we also need to
implement some more long-term
changes to our deterrence and defense
posture
and that's what we have asked our
military commanders to provide options
we will have those option options within
some weeks and then based on the options
from the military commanders we will
make decisions on the more longer term
reset
of nato's deterrence and defense based
on of course what we've already done
and uh and that will be
for the leaders to decide in uh in june
uh but i expect that to be
significantly more
presence
on land troops
advanced weapon systems
but also air defense systems
more
air presence at sea ships submarines
and
in general to do more to strengthen our
collective defense not only with
traditional
military means but also cyber
hybrid space
so we will see a significant
reinforcement all of this will require
more defense spending
and what we see is that allies started
to increase defense spending after 2014
after invasion this year also by
of of of ukraine we have seen new
announcements not least by uh germany
but also by other allies italy denmark
others are now stepping up uh so there
will be more funding for more modern
equipment and this is just reflecting
the brutal new security reality we face
as long as we stand together 30 allies
and invest in our defense we are all
safe and secure
we'll take two final quick questions one
here one online cdf here
thank you very much
mr stoltenberg florian neuhan from setif
german television first question
russia is still claiming that the images
of butcher have been doctored what do
you make of these claims and how certain
are you that these war crimes have
really been committed committed by
russians
and the second question if i may on
sunday ukrainian president zelinski said
it was an historic era of the west of
nato not to offer membership to ukraine
what is your assessment what is was it
wrong not to offer a membership to
ukraine at that time
we have seen the atrocities in budra and
other places in ukraine
these atrocities have taken place
during a period in
which
russia controlled these areas so they
are responsible
[Music]
second we have information from many
different sources
and also from open sources from media
from commercial satellites
satellites and all are telling the same
story
that uh
there have been
uh brutal atrocities
uh
committed um
many
different places in uh in ukraine
and that these have taken place
in a period where russia controlled
these territories
i'm afraid that we will see more
that we will see more examples of the
killing of civil billions
more examples of atrocities
and more examples of uh
targeting
a killing of civilians which actually
are war crimes
because i think we haven't seen
everything that has
taken place because russia still
controls most of these
territories
but
when and if they
withdraw their troops and ukrainian
troops
uh take over i'm afraid they will see
more mass graves more
atrocities and uh and more examples of
war crimes
um
[Music]
so therefore it just highlights the
importance of a thought of investigation
nato allies are providing support to the
un to the international criminal court
to
collect evidence to preserve evidence
to collect
relevant information
and to enable them to
conduct a thought of investigations and
to have a
legal process to make sure that all
those responsible for these atrocities
are held accountable
all facts must be established and we
need
legal processes
nato membership is something which is
decided by 30 allies
30 allies
agreed
in 2008
since 2008 nato allies have provided
support to ukraine
but we have had not no consensus
on granting a
membership
i think now after
uh the invasion of ukraine
uh we need the we need a
uh
a discussion in nato
on how to
support and help
other countries in more or less the same
situation as ukraine
countries that are not member of eu not
member of nato
but are
aspiring to join nato and or the
european union
uh and i think one lesson learned from
ukraine
is that it's better to provide support
sooner than later
so for me this is a very strong message
both
when it comes to need to provide support
to ukraine now
but second also to really
uh
look uh
hard in to have a hard look into what
can we do for countries like georgia
and
boston
and others
[Music]
and the final question online will go to
naomi o'leary from the irish times
thank you very much for taking my
question secretary general um
given that we have public declarations
from the russian regime from mr putin
himself and also from state media that
the intention is to kill quite a broadly
defined group of the ukrainian
population
and we now have evidence of the killings
of civilians in areas under russian
control
does this change anything about what
nato was willing to do
to push russian forces or to help the
push of russian forces out of the areas
of ukraine that are still under russian
control given the likelihood of further
atrocities that you mentioned thank you
we will discuss at the
nato the foreign minister meeting today
and tomorrow tomorrow and the day after
tomorrow what more we can do
and i expect to be the the discussion
about how to provide further military
support what kind of systems how can we
enable the ukrainians
to stand up against invading russian
forces and the support we have already
provided
has an obvious impact we see
that they are able uh to actually take
out a lot of for instance ukrainian
sorry russian armor
and they have been able to actually
defeat them in several places and and
force them to totally change
their the russian war plan they're
moving out of kiev the north to regroup
and to move into the east
so yes i think we will consider what
more we can do
but at the same time
allies agree
that we should not send nato troops into
ukraine
and we should not send nato planes into
ukrainian airspace
and that's because we also have the
responsibility
to prevent
a war between russia and nato
that will cause more death more
destruction
and be even more dangerous
so yes we will
discuss
how we can further support
what more we can do to support ukraine
including what kind of
costs additional costs we can put on on
russia i welcome that allies are
discussing
more sanctions
but i don't expect any ally to be
uh in favor of uh
sending nato troops into ukraine
thank you very much this concludes this
press conference thank you